your business plan needs to also have  emotions attached to it what's emotion  okay so emotion could be enemy is  emotional  what enemy do you have that produces  emotion you ever made a list of 10  things people ever said to you that  really hurts and just kind of mess you  up a little bit you ever heard uh made a  list of 10 things people said that  really  felt very good the compliment like  genuine that you truly believe that  you're like you know my dad one son said  this to me till today I remember this  and I made a very big impact on my life  right it's emotional but enemy is a  driver  you know Jordan look for enemies Kobe  look for enemies Brady look for enemies  it produces something right  sometimes uh if I want to get uh one of  our guys in a company to move it's my  job to find an enemy for them it's your  job as a father for your kids to  sometimes find an enemy that brings out  the best in them